before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
oh crap this is plastic
[Music]
foreign
on with take two Doctor Who reviews time
to talk about praxius this is one that I
remembered bits of and I remember my
general opinion being
uh well it's re
um visiting some of the at least themes
of Orphan 55 and doing them better but
not remembering a heck of a lot more
beyond that
um that base level basically holds true
I can even point to some of the specific
ways in which the environmental
messaging was integrated into the story
that just shows just how badly orphan 55
did it
um but as far as the story unto itself
it didn't leave that much of an
impression but there is some good stuff
here it sort of bits and pieces and it's
sprinkled across a
broke okay
yeah
see ya
episode
um but there are little little glimpses
little flashes of like oh
oh in it and I think in some ways it
actually kind of benefits from being as
close to Orphan 55 as it is because it
makes you go oh they didn't completely
forget how to do messaging oh thank
goodness
um but this is the one that actually the
way it starts is quite well done and I
kind of wish that this happened uh in
Doctor Who a little more often
um but it kind of starts not quite in
media res it's not quite jumping in
after the story's already started it's
just starting us with the perspectives
and getting us to know the normal people
so we start out with these travel
vloggers and this ex-cop and we uh sort
of get established the uh astronaut
um and these things and then the
Companions and The Doctors show up
across these people's stories so like
one of the travel vloggers disappears
the other one runs into Ryan who's like
don't touch the birds there's something
weird going on the cop gets uh an
indication that his astronaut husband is
in Hong Kong he goes to Hong Kong and
there's Graham and Yaz going hold on
what are you doing here and the doctor
shows up in Madagascar with these
research scientists I kind of like the
way they're integrated and it spares us
the normal start of
uh what well doc where are we going I I
don't even know what that accent was but
you know them just like oh what are we
gonna do this time he's like oh well
we'll go here it'll be fun and then
something goes wrong there's something I
don't know it just
feels like it gets started sooner just
by skipping that and having them already
investigating it how did the doctor and
the companions find out that like there
was something we're going on and it was
connected to this this and this well we
get a little techno Babble explanation
but we don't need to sink time into it
they're already looking into something
let's let's just go
I like that it hits the ground running
and I especially during this era would
have kind of appreciated a few more
episodes to start that way I suppose
I'll talk a little bit about the
environmental messaging especially uh in
compared to uh orphan 55 because he
here's what's interesting
the point at which the environmental
message being a very big part like
environmental degradation being a key
part of everything that's going wrong
gets introduced at almost the exact same
point in each story about two-thirds in
about two-thirds into over 55 we find
out this used to be Earth about
two-thirds of the way into Praxis we
find out this is latching on to
microplastics which are in all of our
bodies and it happens at about the same
point but for starters there is a better
build up to the fact that we're trying
to figure out what's going wrong you
know initially with the birds and then
we see people and like okay I'm just
gonna take him in to do this the like
the plasticky thing like creeping up and
then taking it and like you can actually
see it like go in the mouth a little ah
right like it's not like an amazing
effect but it's like legitimately creeps
me out I kind of hate it
um but it means it's effective
um
but you know we get that so obviously
something is wrong that we find out oh
it's the microplastics orphan 55 was not
was not built prior to this around the
mystery of what is this planet really so
suddenly they provide us an answer
that's you know leads us to the
environmental message but it's an answer
to a question nobody was asking not
really whereas here praxius introduces
the environmental aspect the real world
environmental aspect you know the fact
that the planet and every living thing
in it is loaded up with freaking
microplastics at this point and it's our
fault
um it it brings that in as the answer to
a question that was already in the air
not to mention that right off the bat
with the travel vloggers it introduces
the idea of pollution and all this
garbage everywhere and trashing the
planet is introduced right off the bat
so it sets the stage that
environmentalism is at least something
that's going on uh you know
environmental impact and that having
that message it then tells its story
with its questions what's going on and
then circles back to it going
environmentalism pollution uh all this
plastic this is the problem so like it
just integrates it into the story as
opposed to two-thirds of the way through
going this was really error or 55 didn't
do the work at the front end that's a
big part of it but okay but that's like
a comparative thing but I do think it's
a comparison worth making considering
they exist not only within the same show
but within the same series a couple of
episodes apart so I feel like that's
worth doing anyways
um the actual
full answer that there's like a an alien
pathogen that is latching onto the
plastic that's I mean I kind of shrugged
that and go I fine I mean you know what
are what are the Alternatives that
they're the plastic is somehow like
something we did is going to mutate the
plastic that that turns the threat
almost silly
um I actually think it's decently well
balanced because like it establishes
here's something that's really a problem
microplastics and here is a Fantastical
thing that makes it worse but like that
base problem
still a problem I also appreciate that
there's an acknowledgment of the autons
and the doctor discards it because
otherwise the lingering question would
have been how can you do a story with
plastics and not include the autons
they don't work like this not bacterial
like it's a it's a very you know
offhanded not a deep explanation as to
why it can't be them but it's enough I'm
glad it's in there in this episode
almost almost does a better job at
giving weight to um the deaths of some
of these characters I think the best one
is Jamila who is the one of the two um
travel vloggers who dies and you know
you can see them trying to help her you
can see that death really hit the
surviving of vlogger
um except unfortunately there's the one
research scientist who gets taken out by
the crows I don't think he ever really
gets acknowledged
um as having been killed and then at the
very end the other travel vloggers like
I'll go with you how's that what do you
mean if you're with us we can Vlog about
it
your partner in that just died like what
yeah so like it it the episode knows
enough that it has to at least take some
time with one of these but then falls
back into the chip no well it's not
exclusive to General but it's been
bugging me more in chiminal the chiminal
error problem of just being real casual
real callous with the deaths of
characters
um which spoiler alert is going to be a
much bigger issue in two episodes time
but uh we're not there yet we'll get
there
as far as
um what else is going on there's some
good moments for Yaz in this you're
getting this sense that like she's
really starting to really throw herself
into this life and this existence with
the doctor she's willing to you know
activate a Teleport not knowing where
it's going to send her she wants to you
know turn back on her own and get
something that they left behind and she
just kind of assumes she'll be okay
she's getting a little bit Reckless now
this isn't exactly a brand new thing for
a companion to do Clara got Reckless
that's part of why what happened to her
and face the Raven is what happened both
the doctor and Rose kind of got Reckless
that's part of the Arc of their story
and that resulted in Rose being trapped
in a parallel world and whatnot so it's
not it's not the freshest thing in the
world but like it's still a story that I
think has some good dramatic meat on his
bones so I don't have a problem with
sort of introducing those elements to
Yaz I wish more got done with them later
but like they're solid here oh and the
other thing is I feel like another
Pleasant consequence of sort of starting
the story and skipping over the um you
know establishing how the doctor got on
to investigating this you know telling
the companions what they're doing and
skipping all that
by skipping that and starting with the
uh all the people who are already on
Earth we actually get to know them a
little bit better I felt like the cop
especially I think got more time and I
understood him about significantly
better as a character than we've usually
gotten with a lot of the guest uh
character appearances and you know you
get a sense of this self-loathing with
them they have enough time for him to
have this uh talk with graham that I
think actually works uh fairly well to
develop him he's not amazing
which he is you can't love me the way he
says he does it doesn't make sense why
would he I think that's a big part of
why I like this episode starting the way
it does and so that it's not losing time
establishing the patently obvious
somehow the doctor found something to
investigate and started investigating
and like yeah you know we'll take that
for granted and let's allocate the time
to actually developing some of these
other characters at least a little bit
and they're not amazing characters not
astounding performances but they're
they've got a little more depth to them
than um than we sometimes get and I
think that's worth acknowledging oh
there's a there's a tiny little moment
with Yaz that I really like where she's
like genuinely very annoyed that uh when
she used the teleporter that it sent her
to this thing at the bottom of the
Indian Ocean because she thought maybe
it's centered to another planet she was
genuinely irritated that she didn't
discover a new planet what are you
looking like that for
so I discovered an alien planet on my
own again like just some little moments
with her that play well
um the villain twist is
I mean it's functional it's not great
it's not terrible it doesn't undermine
anything and it I actually completely
forgotten that it happened so you know
when Suki reveals herself as actually
being an alien who had infected Earth
with Praxis so she could study it better
and try and figure out how to counteract
it because it had affected her home
world like that's a solid enough
explanation as to why she's here and
what she's doing just you know it
it just it just didn't stick too much
with me especially because it does very
little to uh impact what it is they need
to do and the ultimate resolution
because regardless of whether Suki
portrayed them or not it's not like
she's working with the Praxis infection
she's trying to stop it too she's just
you know she just doesn't care about how
many humans or whether the entire planet
goes down while she does it so like her
methods are bad but her goals are
exactly the same so it's she becomes
like a little bit of a complication but
honestly you could largely remove her
and the story is not particularly
affected because well they still have to
fix the problem they always have to fix
regardless of whether she betrayed them
which I think is probably why I forgot
it happened
um but uh there's again there's like a
little tossed offline where the doctor
is sort of berating herself for not
catching on to Suki earlier she's like
I'm a sucker for a scientist which I
kind of like because it is an
acknowledgment that you know she did and
she's not the only version of the doctor
to do this but gets very excited by like
the science of like oh you're looking
into this investigating that and ooh and
sort of
puts the blinders on a little bit and
doesn't notice maybe some other stuff
that she should have noticed and it's a
it's a tossed off line that uh
acknowledges that and yeah I I like it
there's there's
I'm largely being positive on this but
don't get me wrong it's not incredible
it's not it's it's mid but it's not mid
because everything is white noise it's
mid because the core of it is just it's
fine
and there were little glimmers of
something better but they're not
um core enough elements and they're not
consistent enough to pull the whole
thing up to another level but it's it's
fine
it is a perfectly fine episode and it
has little glimpses little glimmers of
little things or little bits about the
structure that I'm like yeah that's it
that's a good way to do that yeah okay
that's kind of all I've got
this might end up being the shortest
episode review that I've got in this
series because there just isn't that
much to say it's fine
huzzah
praxius you re-wash it lately what'd you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it patreon is what pays
the bills around here enables me to do
this as my living
even if you can't support me there
though there are rewards at every tier
but even if he can't there's links to
other stuff I do in the description the
likes your subscribe also do help me out
but even if you can't do that
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid
you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council is adjourned
[Music]
well it's patreon supporter Shout Out
Time folks so thank you to Robin Moore
Zubin lipfula Tarak the thing that goes
doing in the anime Oliver B Angus
bjornison Linda Walters IMU delki leotha
Boyd toy lowly Becky spark for knobby
lacks the poodle Zach Tracy scrabot
General contact unit Problem Child angry
Casper Tim price Adam RDL Taylor Shayla
gourlay and Brendan Larose thanks so
much for your help you can get your name
right out too check out the rewards in
the patreon
so what they should do should they check
the patreon
[Music]